a lot of the modern maladies that we all
suffer from
anxiety depression isolation etc etc
that we
blame ourselves for right we put a
judgment on ourselves we say that
you know either we're weak or where
there's something wrong with us or we're
sick or something like that i think a
lot of those problems are really just
about the difference between being an
amateur and being a pro and just having
flipping that switch in our mind
and the pro is hard on themselves not
down on themselves but hard on
themselves and an amateur is usually
pretty easy
on themselves the professionals world is
a lot more rigorous
mentally
i'm joined by steven pressfield stephen
welcome to the show
great to have to be here chris thanks
for having me absolute pleasure to have
you on
so we'll have some people listening
whose lives could be changed forever by
turning pro
can we make that happen within the next
hour do you think
we'll give it our best shot here
that would be a pleasure so as a tiny
bit of background i read
both the war of art and turning pro this
year and they had a very profound
impact on how i view the things that i
do in my life and
i wanted to kind of gift the audience
hopefully with the same insights that
your book gave me
uh so first off why did you write
turning pro
um you know it was just a follow-up to
the war of art
because i've you know in the war of art
there is a section as you know called
turning pro
it's the middle section but i felt like
uh i hadn't really said everything that
i wanted to say
and that it needed you know a little
amplification so um
you know so i just kind of amplified it
a little bit it's enough let me ask
you something before we even start how
does uh
the concept of of resistance in the war
of art how does that uh
how does that affect what what you do
where did it uh impact your life
so resistance thankfully
in podcasting is not as much of
a burden to bear reason being
that you naturally are on this treadmill
with the other person you have this
external accountability right
so i i can't just stop this conversation
if resistance arises
because you're there and you can't stop
this conversation because i'm here and
i'm here to help you
i'll ask you a question you'll help me
so resistance to me
um manifests much more when i'm writing
newsletters which again
your experience is writing book sitting
down blank page in front of you
and you struggle um but it's interesting
to for me to have that dichotomy and
there may be people listening as well
for whom they have resistance that
manifests very strongly in certain areas
of their life
and then doesn't in others and i
certainly think things that you can do
with other people
uh team sports um you know you turn up
to training for rugby
and the resistance kind of doesn't
really seem to be there
you turn up to do a solo session in the
gym and you're just swimming in
resistance right so that's something
that was an insight that i gained this
year
okay great so yeah
that was something that i saw i
absolutely adored the idea of turning
pro
so how do we define an amateur let's
start before we even get into
professionals
how do we define an amateur one of the
ways i think is
an amateur as a as a as a rule is kind
of a weekend warrior
and uh an amateur when they hit uh
adversity are going to gonna quit
you know um that's probably the the
ultimate
sign and i lived for years as an amateur
you know and dropping the ball of
fumbling the ball
on the one-yard line to use an american
football analogy
that kind of thing being unable to
finish something whenever adversity
would
would strike i would cave into it um
and uh an amateur there are many other
aspects of an amateur but an amateur
usually
does a lot of talking about what they're
going to do
whereas the professional usually just
shuts up and does the work
um and uh i think
uh a lot of
the modern maladies that we all suffer
from
anxiety depression isolation
etc etc that we we blame ourselves for
right we
we put a judgment on ourselves we say
that you know either we're
weak or we're you know there's something
wrong with us or we're sick or
we're there we're sick or something like
that we have some
neurotic you know issue whatever it is i
think a lot of those problems are really
just about the difference between being
an amateur and being a pro
and just having you know flipping that
switch in our mind
and uh you know we'll get into this a
lot i'm sure but a pro
is is um hard on themselves
you know not really not down on
themselves but hard on themselves
um and an amateur is usually pretty easy
on themselves um the
professionals world is a lot more
rigorous
mentally and and emotionally
psychologically
how did being an amateur before you
took the the step to becoming pro you
say you've got two stages to your life
before and after you turned pro how did
the
amateur lifestyle manifest for you
before you
made that change kind of like what i was
just
just talking about chris like uh um
my life was pretty chaotic you know not
not necessarily in a bad sense i mean
there was a lot of kind of adventure
going on a lot of drama and stuff like
that and uh i met a lot of people that
turned out to be interesting people
and went with a lot of places to turn to
be interesting places
but i wasn't getting anything done and
and i was feeling worse and worse and
worse about it
and in general i was sort of in one form
or another
running away from my my real
work my real calling in you know running
away physically going to different
places
and running away you know in different
activities that were
um what i call in the book shadow
activities
not the real activities they were close
to them but they were not really them
um and at the moment that you know
i finally did turn pro i really just
decided look
this is my calling this is what i want
to do which is writing
and i just i have to organize my life in
such a way that i can do it
i can't allow chaos to dominate
everything and and my you know um
and and my resistance be defeating me
every every morning you know
procrastination and all that kind of
stuff
so you mentioned uh one of the the key
points that kind of self-identifies an
amateur which is these
shadow activities or even shadow careers
how can someone work out if they're
going through with a shadow activity or
a shadow career
uh it's uh let me see if i can define it
first chris and then um
it's all obviously nobody can make that
judgment except the person themselves
and it's very very hard a lot of times
but like uh
i worked in the movie business in in la
as a screenwriter for
you know about 10 years or so 10 or 12
years and one of the phenomenons that
you see there phenomena that you see
there a lot
is there such a thing as entertainment
lawyers you know their entire law firms
that are about negotiating deals and if
you're an actor if you're a director if
you're a writer
you have an entertainment lawyer and the
entertainment lawyer
you know sometimes will actually find
work for you and
certainly will negotiate all the deals
for you and it's sort of a commonplace
there
that a lot of entertainment lawyers want
to be writers
or want to be producers and i think that
and i've talked to people they admit it
they laugh and they admit it
that they sort of chose being a lawyer
because it was kind of adjacent
to the creative field you know they
didn't chose to be like
oil and gas lawyers or corporate lawyers
they chose to be entertainment lawyers
and i think this applies sometimes to
agents
as well they're sort of in a field
that's adjacent to a creative field
but is not really is not really that
field
and um i can understand it makes a lot
of sense you figure well if i go to law
school
i'm going to have a degree i'm going to
have something i can fall back on i'm
going to have an actual
job that pays me whereas if i just
plunge in being an
actor or writer or director god knows
what will happen
then another another kind of
manifestation of this is chris is um
this is more i don't want to be sexist
here but it's more women that kind of
fall into this
and that is to sort of but men too so
women that don't get mad at me
people will be somebody else's assistant
they'll kind of sign up to work for
a musician or a director or a producer
or something like that
and what they really want to do is they
really want to produce themselves so
they really
want to be a musician themselves and so
they have this kind of
shadow career and um
i know that you're doing a thing of six
months sober and stuff like that
and i think that um a lot of times
addictions are shadow careers
i could get into this in great detail
but i think that a lot of times people
will
if they get into alcohol they get into
drugs they get into heroin they get into
you know
all the things you can get into their
life
as an alcoholic or their life as a as a
drug addict
becomes their shadow work of art
and rather than write the book that they
were going to write or
or produce the movie or whatever it is
they were going to do
they create this their own sort of
personality
their own drama their own their life
becomes
like um like a movie you know it's it's
got everything right
sometimes it you know it it even has
violence and
god knows what else um so i'm probably
wandering on too long but there's also
another
keep going there's another phenomenon in
america in the states
particularly in the south particularly
in a place like new orleans
and maybe in the uk you guys have this
too
where people will become quote-unquote
characters
you know the crazy old lady that has 33
cats or you know the guy with the hat
that wanders around the french quarter
whatever
and what they're sort of doing there and
not that there's anything wrong with
being a colorful character
but they're to me rather than writing
their novel or
or starting their business they create
this
image this thing of them themselves this
personality of themselves
that that becomes their own sort of work
of art
but um and in some cases i guess that's
cool
but not if it's eating you up inside
and you really know on some level i
should be doing i should be doing more
with my with my life than that you know
i spent a little bit of time last year
in new orleans and i know precisely the
characters that you mean there's a
lady that i saw at one of the parades
with
she looked like mary poppins purple hat
a green feather bower like two walking
sticks dancing crazy to the
jazz music outside so i know exactly
that um i had aubrey marcus so i know
that you're a friend of
uh i had on the show last year and he
said something that really stuck with me
and i think it
ties in with what you're talking about
here and he
talks about how people protect
themselves by building up
caricats caricatures of themselves by
wrapping themselves in ego he says the
reason for that is without vulnerability
you don't ever actually have to put
anything on the line because if the ego
or the character that you're playing
fails well that's not me i didn't fail
the character i'm playing fails but the
converse of this
which he identified and i absolutely
love was that he said
the ego is incapable of receiving love
it can only receive
praise and i think that distinction is
really important the fact that when you
play this metacognizant character
you're not you fully open and actualized
you're some
analog of that you're all of the you're
all of the veneers of it but none of the
core of it
um the praise the the failures that you
get don't hurt
but the praise that you get doesn't feel
like love because you know that it's not
you and i can attest to this as someone
who
played kind of a big name on campus
party boy for a long time
i realized that that veneer a lot of the
time was because i was
um insecure or ashamed about the fact
that i had particular
uh interests and curiosities that i
didn't think other people would think
were cool
so i didn't i i thought i had to talk
about partying and girls and booze and
blah blah blah
because i couldn't talk about the fermi
paradox or
what consciousness is or why it is that
we have sexual selection
you know what i mean like they're all of
these things and maybe a lot of the
listeners who are
tuned into this as well i think everyone
has elements of amateurs in them right
everyone's an amateur in probably some
area of their life yes
yes you touched on something that i
really love
what do amateurs and addicts have in
common
um well i i think that they're they're
both artists
you know that they both have
um and that's why so many musicians are
addicts and so many artists are addicts
it's
it you know it's not an accident um i
think that they have
and they feel within them a self
that wants to be born and work that
wants to be
produced that wants to be brought out
into the world
and um and it terrifies
both people terrifies the artist and
terrifies the addict and i think what
you were just saying what mark
what aubry said was that um
rather than be vulnerable rather than
really express that thing which is of
course really hard because then you're
really
letting yourself up for being you know
particularly these days you know
massacred
um you will uh
someone who goes into an addiction
that's really sort of what you were just
talking about it's a
it's a second self that's not really the
self so that
you know whatever happens there how what
any bad
consequences that come from that are not
as bad
it's a protective thing are not as bad
as really
trying to be the artist or to speak of
or to follow the the things that you
really want
that you really are interested in you
really do want to pursue and you're
afraid you won't be cool
you're afraid that people will think you
know what kind of a you know kind of a
guy is this guy interested in this stuff
he should be interested rugby and that
kind of stuff
so and of course that's that's part of
growing up too you know when you're
young
peer pressure is tremendous and it you
know very few people have the guts
to to really be themselves it only takes
i think
a lot of pain living that artificial
self
before the moment comes where you
finally say i just can't do this [ __ ]
anymore you know i've just gotta
i gotta be you know i've gotta i gotta
be me whatever you know
i really loved there was an example he
used i think you used charlie
sheen as one of the examples and he said
that the addict's life is really boring
um from the outside it looks it looks
super colorful
but in reality it's the same boring
excuses the same boring turning up late
to work the same
boring story about how many drugs or
whatever it was that you had last night
there's no trajectory right it's
groundhog day over and over
and i've never it is ground out there
yeah i've never heard that said about
addicts before because you see
and it almost gets romanticized in
movies and popular culture as well
yes the addict lifestyle rock and roller
if you've seen that wonderful british
film
um has this almost
super romanticized view of how the
addict spends their time he's a dying
artist but he's so and
and you're like yeah that that is true
but it isn't in place of art
it's instead of our it's not as if you
can substitute the art
for the addiction and it still is
beautiful it's everything that takes up
the space of the addiction with none of
the beauty
yes and it's funny that when you turn
pro
and you start really doing your work
then your life from the outside
really does look boring you know it's
all of a sudden you know you're getting
up early you're going to the gym
you're going to your studio or whatever
it is and somebody looking for
one of your old buddies that used to
know you in your
addicted days you know they said what
happened to you man i mean it used to be
fun
to hang out with you now look at you and
all you're doing is practicing
ballet steps in your studio or whatever
it is
but um so it is interesting
how what we do think is is is exciting
is really boring as hell
and what we do what looks to be boring
on the outs of course it's not boring
you know like
people used to say to me i think i even
wrote this in turning pro that
i used to work in this office here where
i am right now that my desk used to face
the other way faces into that wall
and people would say to me well you know
don't you want to have a view outside
how can you
how can you look like that but the but
the answer is i'm
living up here you know the world that
i'm inhabiting
or the world that the artist is having
inhabiting in their studio
may look pretty dumb from the outside
but inside a lot of stuff is going on
it's you know game of thrones is
going on inside there so you're and
if and if you're really doing your work
then you are getting traction you're not
just spinning your wheels constantly
it feel you talk a lot about tribes and
about how the
uh social imperative the the social
influence of other people
um can cause us to compromise and dilute
down
our professionality i suppose and our
ability to overcome resistance and it
makes total sense with this right like
why wouldn't you want to do the thing
that everyone else thinks is cool that
just
looks like so much for oh he's leading
this life and that's been turned up to
11 with
instagram and facebook and tick tock and
yeah youtube now
you know people live these meta lives
where they
exist only to create the content they go
on holiday purely to film the content to
make to put
do you know what i mean this is going
back to this sort of meta life that
people have um and that happens in again
small parts for everyone um but
i i really think the bravery to be able
to be called
boring is a or weird or different is a
a powerful mechanism because as my
good friend george mcgill says ordinary
people get ordinary results
extraordinary people get extraordinary
results the closer that you get to
normal
the closer you regress to the mean of
the results everyone else gets
like that's precisely never hurt that's
wonderful
so think about anyone kobe bryant
michael jordan
these guys don't have normal work ethics
even
in an environment of super normal humans
they're still standouts tiger woods
um his the relationship he had with his
dad was so
crazy when he was growing up but
look at what the result was on the back
end of that you know you
have to have extraordinary effort get
extraordinary results and
um yeah i think casting off the tribe is
an important part of that
yeah another way of looking at that and
i just actually heard this the other day
from a friend of mine scott mann who is
a retired
lieutenant colonel in the um green
berets and he was talking about
it's sort of like the maslow pyramid you
know where you
at the at the bottom of the pyramid is
is sort of the tribal
uh which of course we were
where peer pressure is everything you
know to conform and to be one of the
one of the gang and of course we evolved
as
you know in a tribal environment you
know for hundreds of thousands of years
is like the primitive hunting band
but then you're kind of in the lower end
of the thing but when you get to this
top part of the of the
of the pyramid then you're getting that
kind of maslow area of
self-actualization or individuation you
know where you kind of have cut free
from the the um the demands of the tribe
and the
and the expectations of the tribe and
you're really becoming
whoever it is that you were born to be
whatever your individual
essence is and it's of course it like
with michael jordan or kobe bryant it's
lonely
up there you know um and that's just
that's part of the price
how do people swallow that price then
how do people learn to pay it
is it getting used to being cast off by
the tribe a little bit
more each day how do they do it uh
you know i'm not sure that i can really
speak to being in that
i'm trying to be but i don't know but i
do think that you
i'll just speak from my own experience
you um
first of all it's to me it's not a
sacrifice at all
i feel much happier being in that in
that place
up there because i feel like i'm really
uh
in my own skin and doing you know
serving my own muse
whatever that is but the other thing is
that
i think as you do evolve into that
into that place
you sort of leave people behind in a way
i know that sounds kind of ego maniacal
or
you know but they're they're um
um i'm thinking of david o russell
movies like the fighter and joy if you
remember that one
and also uh silver linings playbook he
talks about this a lot where he'll have
a character
like the mickey i forgot his name played
by mark wahlberg in the fighter
who is in this family where everybody
you know he wants to be a fighter that's
his thing his brother was a fighter
et cetera et cetera in the movie joy
starring uh jennifer lawrence she plays
this
gal that started the mop the miracle mop
on this home shopping network and both
of them were
embedded in families where the family
was sabotaging them
you know the family uh like the fighter
the
his mom was his his booking agent and
she would
the start of the movie she books him
into this fight where the guy outweighs
him by 15 pounds and he just massacres
him you know
it's like what are you putting me in you
know and so in other words when you sort
of
if you leave people like that behind or
you just disengage
from them it's not a bad thing you know
you feel like i got rid of something
that was really holding me back
so um it's kind of painful i'm a guy
that feels guilty and is very loyal
you know like to a fault but
sometimes you do have to move follow
your own star
or wherever it goes and not everybody
wants to go on that same path with you
there's this wonderful quote by james
clear
changing your habits often requires you
to change your tribe
each tribe has a set of shared
expectations
behaviors that conform to the shared
expectations are attractive
behaviors that conflict with the shared
expectations are unattractive
it's hard to go against the group often
changing your habits requires you to
change your tribe i love that
i think it's absolutely true and one of
the things there
is your level of aspiration i mean
a lot of times it isn't that you've
changed
um your outlook or anything like that
it's just you want to be better
you know you just you won't accept the
level
of achievement or commitment or whatever
that people around you
are very comfortable in you know and
like michael jordan is a classic example
of that you know where
he had to be really rough on his
teammates
he was an absolutely the only way he
knew how to do it
yeah um and you could see i mean i guess
we're both talking about watching the
last dance have you seen that's it
wonderful you know where he would
actually you could see on camera when he
was being interviewed where he got uh
he would get upset you know like that
one thing where he goes break and he
gets up from the chair again
ends the interview because i guess he
felt a little bad about
how hard he was on people but he wanted
to be at
his level of aspiration was different
than the tribe
and he had to bring them with him when
you look at it
when you look at it in the cold light of
day with perspective
the choice really is between being less
than you can be
to appease other people or being all
that you can be
and perhaps upsetting someone and like
for me
it takes a lot of bravery to do that you
know and you're right as well about the
age thing
um as a younger
person guy or girl you just that
confidence to go against the group you
know everything's new and novel in the
world scary and big
over time it's everyone's dad or
everyone's uncle right you know the
uncle that just doesn't give a [ __ ]
like he'll fart farts at dinner
and decides to go play golf four times a
week or do
he does his thing um and i think that
like that level of uncleness
is something that we can all aspire to
have
yes i've all for that yeah
um final thing before we move on to
what a pro is and and the difference
between that and an amateur
how can someone self-diagnose
if they're an amateur who's chomping at
the bit to turn pro
how can someone identify the things
we've got the shadow activity we've
potentially got the addiction
is there anything else well i would
think anybody that's listening to us
talk right now and is in that state it's
probably
very obvious to them to themselves you
know
i know if i were listening to this my
former self i would say holy [ __ ] that's
me
that's that's exactly what i'm doing you
know and i think we
we all do know that you know it's very
clear to us we're sort of running away
from it
you know all day long trying to keep
that that perception from breaking
through
so yeah i think it's it's more obvious
yeah obviously
good good person themselves you know
we've done uh we've done our job in the
first half so okay how do we define a
professional how are they different from
an amateur
well one of the things that i do say is
just sort of like what you were reading
there um
a a professional has professional habits
and an amateur has amateur habits and so
if we kind of look at the
if we look at the way we live our day
you know
um do we get up at a certain time in the
in the morning you know and do we always
get up at that time or something
like that do we do we have
an aspiration you know are we aiming at
something um
are we are we ruthless with ourselves
you know are uh will we not allow
ourselves to slack off
or you know or only once in a while have
a
cheat meal or something like that or or
are we
um just just so easy on ourselves you
know that
we're just kind of bouncing around to
miss to that to the other thing
um i i think a professional is usually
defined i think
by by their aspiration what it is
they're trying to do
you know if you if you ask a writer
that's a that's a real pro writer
what are you what are you trying to do
they could probably tell you
the book they're working on they know
exactly what it is they want to do they
probably know the next one after that
and the one after that and if they don't
they know that they
want at least they know the path that
they want to be on
you know whereas i'm thinking about my
own amateur days if you ask me
what i what i want to do i wouldn't have
a clue you know i would bounce from one
thing to another another thing is
i think i remember you know i used to
live in
in a in my in my chevy van you know i
used to
you know i didn't think of it as
homeless at the time but i used to live
in that kind of situation
and i remember when i would wake up in
the morning
you know in my mattress in the back of
my van wherever the hell i was
i would sort of have to have like a five
minute session with myself
just to tell myself who i was
and what i was trying to do with the day
and i had no clue you know unless i was
in some
some scene you know where there were
people and i knew i had to
you know meet so and so or whatever but
in other words that was that's was a
total amateur situation
where i had no real no goal no
aspiration
nothing that was uh that was internal
that was driving me from my heart
i was not in i was not in in touch
with uh my muse or whatever you want to
say whatever that inspiration is
i don't know i'm probably babbling a
little bit at all steven i absolutely
love this and it's so insightful
um something that i've just realized
there
going back to the addict thing i wonder
whether
having multiple projects or having a lot
of different
pathways on the go is a form of
addiction
so myself and a number of friends i know
we rationalize doing lots of things as
hedging
and we say by having that i'm spreading
risk
i've got multiple streams whatever it
might be
but that's just a form of resistance as
well that's just a form of fear from
going all in
on the one thing that you know i would
absolutely define it
i would absolutely define it as a form
of resistance and
i get a lot of letters from people like
that where people will say
i've got so many ideas i just don't know
which one
to follow you know and it's resistance
throwing these shiny objects at us you
know like uh
what do they call a chaff like when uh a
missile is trying to track
an airplane the airplane will release
this these uh
you know uh what aluminum foil
shiny objects and the missile doesn't
know what to do and it gets lost right
and i think we will create those shiny
objects ourselves
to distract ourselves you know and i
think a lot of times when you read
the biographies or you listen to
somebody like bob dylan or somebody like
that talking about their life
there was no plan b you know
that they were they were all in for
whatever it was
so um yeah i think
if when i find myself having like a
bunch of projects
i will really try to sit down and and
whittle those away and just kind of be
ruthless in throwing the it's not so
easy to do it's hard to in fact i'm in a
place like that right now
or i've got two or three things and i'm
not sure which one to go
it's very hard but i do i do think that
that
the idea of hedging your bets is not
such a great idea i think you're correct
and you know to continue to sing michael
jordan's song
michael played golf as a way to calm
down
but he wasn't trying to be a pro golfer
whilst he was trying to be a pro
basketballer
no that's true exactly yeah all in on
basketball
hilariously i didn't know that he got
him played baseball um which is like
just
such but even when he played baseball he
was all in on baseball
you know he wasn't i'll keep on foot in
the door with this thing
like he was he was all in and i i
definitely think that that's one of the
more
pernicious ways that resistance can
manifest because it
looks like productivity it looks like
achievement
both internally and externally and what
were we just saying about the way that
the tribe
and this kind of socialized reward is
important oh
stephen you've got so many things on the
go like you've got three books
and a podcast and you've youtube and the
blah blah blah
and you think again what is it it's
boring
like it looks from the outside in really
exciting and varied
but from the inside out you're not
getting the work done you're just
constantly spinning these plates
desperately trying to stop any of them
from falling down
yeah now i would i might disagree with
you chris on the michael jordan playing
baseball thing
and of course we would we won't know if
until we have him
here and he would tell us i'll get him
eventually but if if you remember
now i've watched this thing like five
different times so i was very familiar
with the last dance
if you remember his dad died was
murdered
right before that and i think maybe for
him
baseball was just sort of a way of
taking some time out
because his dad always wanted him to
play baseball and
and of of allowing that grief
to process itself because when the time
was right
he went back to basketball you know um
so it was baseball
do you think perhaps no i think in some
way
maybe it was sometimes you know
like we're talking here now chris about
um
sort of relentlessly powering forward
towards a goal you know
but sometimes you need to break take a
break from that
you know we are human and
um in a way i think somehow maybe
you know i'm psychoanalyzing michael
jordan which is a crazy thing if we only
had him here
uh maybe he just needed with baseball
just to be a regular guy
for a little while you know just to be
one of the guys on the team and then go
back
to being the greatest that ever lived
you know
um but i don't know i'm just uh i think
that's guessing i think that's a really
good insight and
that's something i would be very
impressed if you have the answer for
this
how do you determine when
you've been ruthless enough with
yourself
basically there's always a challenge
between being sufficiently compassionate
when you've hit your limit
and pushing yourself hard enough to find
where it is
yeah i'm gonna disappoint you chris
because i'm not gonna have an answer
here
i i really all i can say is it's it's
really hard to know
you know um i know for me there
certainly had been times where i really
did back off
and just let things go and um
and a lot of times that was good um
but i'm not sure why i don't know i
wouldn't i wouldn't know how to define
it
it's intuitive isn't it it's it's a
question i've asked you're not you must
be like the tenth
guest that i've asked that question to
and it is everyone has the same answer
which is essentially that
it's just an intuition it's a notion you
feel it you sense it
um and you know when you've gone too far
there's been some times where
i've pushed myself so hard with work
that i've not been able to get out of
bed
for a couple of days you know you just
have like a miniature breakdown
and i'm just tired and lethargic and i
can't think and my thoughts are muddy
and then i come i snap out of it and i'm
like wow i
guess i did a little bit and it's always
after an intense period of work you know
you do two weeks three weeks of like
just non-stop bang bang bang bang bang
and then that happens and you think okay
that's my limit and again what we're
talking about over time we get older
we understand our tolerance is a little
bit more we're able to
see and feel and use intuition a little
bit more yeah
more adaptly so yeah i think there's
another thought
the the whole sort of concept of an off
season
you know that you know in certain
sports you know in practically all
sports before people became
a year-round fitness kind of thing there
would be an off season
right and maybe that's makes sense i
mean if you think about
uh the primitive hunting band that we're
that's where
we're living that that's our our guts
right that's our dna
i'm sure they sort of went out they
hunted they chased the
mastodons you know an insane thing then
they brought the
food back the bacon back to the cave and
i'm sure they took a couple of weeks off
you know
and maybe that is kind of a rhythm that
we might
you know emulate a little bit ourselves
because we can drive ourselves crazy
trying to get to the top of that pyramid
you know and self-actualize and all that
you know it's a good question i wish i
had you know a meter that i
you know could you know a switch would
go off and say time to take a break
like a thermometer yeah yeah i get it
exactly uh it's
david allen ism where he says your
ability to deploy power is directly
proportional to your ability to relax
oh really that's good too wonderful yeah
he's um
and that again like is that a form of
addiction and addiction to constantly
doing the same thing the inability to
let go
and what we're seeing here is that the
tighter and tighter circles
of nuance and complexity that we're
talking about as you
pivot from being an amateur to being a
professional when you commit to
something the
problems don't necessarily go away they
just get more nuanced and more
but you know the other thing is i think
being a professional doesn't mean that
you have to be grinding
every minute of the day you know like if
if you and i were
uh if the olympic games were three years
away
and we were whatever an athlete that was
going to compete in such a thing
and uh and we had a brilliant coach like
a phil jackson or something like that
i'm sure that he would break those three
years up to uh for us
into periods of intense effort and then
a break
you know and the whole thing aiming to
to peak
at that time you know three three years
from now
so i think being a professional does not
necessarily mean
you're grinding every minute of the day
i really like we keep on coming back to
it because it's an easy analogy to use
when we talk about athletics and about
sports stars yeah and
i think there's so much that
anyone who isn't playing sport can take
from people who do
so when you think about just how refined
a sports star's life is to maximize
their performance they're eating right
they're sleeping right
they're working on their mental game
they're doing their accessory movements
they're doing their conditioning they're
doing drills technique
training they're working with a mindset
coach they're working with
you know every base is covered i i have
a friend
um alex o'connor who was on the show
recently
um and he i would be surprised if he
doesn't become one of the
the best known vegan philosophers on the
planet peter singer's sort of style
guy um but i know and i've told him
before i'm like man if you want to be
the person you want to be the new hitch
you want to be the new christopher
hitchins
if that's who you want to be you need to
be refined in every area of your life
because he's made the commitment to
being vegan but he only eats three meals
i'm like dude you need to have
20 meals you need to be able to someone
asks you about it
you've got the most balanced diet you've
got the best sleep do you know what i
mean like when someone wants to go all
in on something
what is this what's all this stuff over
here why are you not committed to this
if it's in service of something that you
genuinely love that you genuinely
believe is you're calling in life
all of these one percent are in service
of that
yeah that's true now i'm going to take
the opposite side of that chris
i know you you you are um
do you know who bobby jones the golfer
is is that ring a bell at all no
bobby jones was an american golfer from
atlanta who won
the grand slam in 1929 i think it was
u.s amateur british amateur
us open british open as an amateur he
was uh
um just kind of he founded the masters
you know he um anyway
one of the all-time great players ever
and he was an amateur all the way
through and um
that was back in the days when amateur
meant something different but he was a
lawyer
and he worked full-time as a lawyer and
the way his year would go
is when winner came around he was from
atlanta
you know he would just go to work as a
lawyer wouldn't touch a club all winter
long
and then when the when it started to get
warm in the spring he would sort of
the phrase he used was play himself back
into shape
and he would just kind of get and by the
time but somehow he was able to do it
where he just beat everybody like
the great disc golfers of their day who
at that time was walter hague and gene
saraz and
these names i'm sure don't mean anything
to you but
during his period bobby jones period
these other guys never won
a major tournament that bobby jones was
in
he anyway so the point i'm trying to
make here is that
there's uh there are different ways to
peek
now the other thing about bobby jones
they said about him was that in a
four-day
tournament he would lose between 12 and
18 pounds
just from burning it off in the and it
was root
you played in neckties in those days and
it was routine
they would sweat that he had to like cut
the necktie off with a knife at the end
so in other words at the the level that
he was performing
was at the kobe bryant level but he did
not have
you know the coaches and then all that
sort of thing so
i'm i'm not lobbying for one way or the
other but there are definitely
definitely different ways to do it even
in that situation what we're seeing is
someone who is incredibly present
when they're doing it right you know if
you're losing 18 pounds over four days
it's because you yeah
every fiber every cell in your body is
focused on the task
yes that he was able to really bring it
you know when when uh when when that
counted in fact
this is off the subject a little bit
here but in the year that he won the
grand slam
his main challenge was not to screw it
up
it's like from the start of the year he
sort of knew i can win all four of these
things you know
all i have to do is show up and be my
and bring my game you know and he he
talked about
i'm gonna wander off a little bit here
but they were like he heard of
one other player might have been a
baseball player who was shaving back in
the days when he had
razor blades that went into a into a
thing and
he dropped the blade and his reflexes
were so sharp
he grabbed it and he cut his hand
and he couldn't play you know whatever
it was baseball
and so part of bobby jones day was
don't do that you know don't do anything
that's gonna happen and uh anyway i
don't know that's apropos
nothing but just i love this i love to
read about bobby jones and talk about
him
his um a lot of the stuff that we do we
self sabotage right
both consciously and unconsciously but
avoiding doing
stupid things i literally did between
it's so dumb uh three days before i
snapped my achilles i did a tweet that
said avoid stupidity
don't chase don't chase success uh and
then obviously a couple of days later i
managed to rupture my achilles
um but yeah like how did you do that
chris what
how what what were the circumstances
playing crazy if you don't mind my
asking playing cricket which is the most
british way that you can rupture an
achilles so
uh batting and cricket and just setting
off so exactly the same way
that kobe bryant did in fact if anyone
that's listening is interested
there's a 3d rendering on youtube of
precisely how kobe bryant's physiology
worked
during the match as his achilles snapped
and if you have your heel off the ground
a little bit
and then you push back what you're doing
is you're contracting the muscle
whilst the eccentric portion of the
movement is happening
and that's one of the real um
sort of perfect storms for it that
you've got this
pressure and then eventually your heel
hits the floor and all of that
elasticity gets snapped and it
it pulls because you can hang a car off
your achilles tendon
but really yeah so you can think about
how much force is going through it
but it's more to do with that that
snapping that jerking motion that comes
from the plyometric
um so i mean that was that was a that
was a an ugly day but
even with that like i might i might sort
of just tell
yourself and the viewers what my um
experience upon reading turning pro was
and
this has been a a defining
characteristic of this year for me
that a lot of people and myself as well
i'm still recording in my bedroom
it's still me and one guy we're an
independent show it's not like we have
this
big team or some production company
behind us um
which means that it's much easier to be
an amateur
it's much easier for me to just oh it's
a side thing
it's a hobby it's a this that and the
other um and part way through the year
upon reading the war of art i thought
hang on you love doing this this is
something that you're compelled to do
it's something that you're called to do
why why are you not going all in why are
you allowing
these other areas to distract you why
are you not
turning up 10 minutes early to every
interview that you do
why are you not preparing as much as you
can for every guest that you do
all of these things all of these foots
one foot out of the door situations
were me doing the aubrey marcus well if
the episode's a little bit crap
i didn't prepare all that much therefore
it's not a comment on my capacity
i could have done better i just chose
not to you
inoculate yourself from public failure
by assuring your failure privately
um and uh yeah that's very well said
yeah yeah it's uh it's something i've
thought about a lot this year
uh really really have and i hope that
we can start to give everyone that's
listening
the impetus the the ability to get over
that inertia
to move out of amateur and into
professionals so we've spoken about
going all
in we've talked about the fact that you
need to be um
ruthless with yourself what are some of
the other um
heuristics that people can use to ensure
that they
make the transition from amateur to
professional as
well as they can uh you know i
i i never have like checklists
or anything like that because it's so
it's so um
uh unique to each individual like in
turning pro
there was a passage about roseanne cash
the singer and the dream that she had
can i tell that story here for your
uh this to me was like the kind of the
ultimate turning pro moment
roseanne cash is johnny cash's daughter
and
she had a career at the start of her
career that was quite successful kind of
as a
you know she had a bunch of hits and um
as a singer but she always had she
always wanted to be a songwriter and a
singer she wanted to do concept albums
that really came from her heart rather
than
um you know picking songs that other
people had written
so she had a dream and it's really
important that
that this is a dream because it shows
it's coming from a part of her
right and in the dream oh she one of the
people that she idolized was linda
ronstadt the singer
so in the dream she was at a party and
she was sitting at a bench
and linda ronstadt was on one side she
was on the other
in between them was an older man that
she somehow knew his name was
art capital a-r-t
and art was an intense conversation with
linda ronstadt in the dream
and roseanne was kind of trying to get
into the conversation you know
and suddenly this guy turned to her art
and looked her up and down with utter
contempt
and said we don't have anything to do
with dilettantes
and roseanne as she describes this in in
her book composed she said i woke up
from this dream
shaken to the core because she felt like
she had really been called out
this was really the truth and she says
from that moment on i changed my life i
changed
everything about my life i changed the
way
i wrote i attacked music i started
studying painting
i started getting in shape physically i
started you know getting working out
i started studying voice and this and
this
and she started attacking certain habits
that she had like she one of the things
she said
was she had a habit of daydreaming of
just kind of getting off into a fog
and she said she would like teach
herself to snap back out of that
and she also had a habit of like not
working as hard as she
could on some settling for something
like that
and also of writing a song or preparing
a song that was good enough
you know but it wasn't it didn't have
the element of madness to it that she
was looking for
so that's kind of a case where she
herself decided she just knew she knew
i've got to change
i've gotta i can't keep going the way
i'm going so she sort of invented what
what the changes were that she was going
to make she was going to study this
and study that and get up earlier and
eat better and
all that sort of thing so in other words
i think that
once we kind of make that commitment
we'll know we'll know what we're
what we're supposed to do we'll know
where we've been sloughing off eating
sugar or whatever it is like you know
that kind of thing that's a beautiful
story
i really really love that and then you
yourself
was it the the first time you turned pro
you locked yourself in a
a hut in the woods for like um 15
a week or something like that wow that
is great
that's great because the way people see
it know what but i really thinking back
over it
because i have been thinking back i
probably have had maybe 15 turning pro
moments
you know there wasn't just one you know
um
but what i did then was i i saved enough
money and moved to a small affordable
house
a little house cabin in the woods
stephen there's a cabin in the woods
they call it smaller
woods but yeah so i really just sort of
locked myself in this underwater
thing where i couldn't leave because i
knew that my resistance was so strong
that i would quit
otherwise so anyway but we do have a
bunch of these turning pro moments not
just one
do you think that something symbolic
like that
is uh a potential tool that people can
use
yes definitely to commit to because
symbolically
yeah i mean look at roseanne cash's
dream you know there's a guy called
art i mean you know
really that's the way the mind works so
yeah
i mean i wonder if your achilles injury
wasn't a way of
making you focus on you know the
podcasting and stuff like that
very well might be but don't let me
psychologically hey i i would love it
um one thing an example that the
listeners will be familiar with
um from last year for me was i've had a
back injury as well um a couple of
bulging discs
and i read a book by the world's expert
on a spinal pain guy called dr stewart
mcgill i had him on the show
i really enjoyed him um and i thought i
keep on going to different physios
nothing really seems to be working
i'm going to make a commitment i'm going
to make a pilgrimage to go and see him
in canada so i'm in america i've done
this
road trip that i mentioned where i went
through new orleans and nashville and a
bunch of other places
and at the end of that as opposed to i'd
already booked my flight home
but stu very very kindly said if you
come out fishing with me and you catch a
fish
i'll do your consultation for you um and
i decided to sack the flight off that
was going home so that was you know
maybe
700 pounds um i flew from
um norfolk to uh toronto then rented a
car
then drove for two hours north on my own
to go and see this
like crazy white mustache man
uh and met him and his wonderful wife
and their dog and stayed
stayed with them and spent the evening
and he did this
like brilliant assessment and that to me
was a symbolic
it was like a pilgrimage right it was
like a yeah a journey that i made and as
soon as i came back my compliance
on the things that he told me to do was
maniacal monomaniacal i did if he said
it i did it
and part of that was the pilgrimage this
symbolic gesture that i'd made to him
and myself
yeah that's a great thing you know
there's uh we're probably running out of
time i'll see if i can cram this up
we've got loads of time to keep going
there's a wonderful book about
interpretation of dreams called inner
work
by robert johnson which i highly
recommend to
anybody he's a junior and one of the
things he said
is when you have a dream that's a pow a
real powerful dream
do something physical in your life
to to uh memorialize that and so your
trip to canada
that was that and i think there's
there's a lot to be said for that like
here i don't know if you can see this
you know i had that
dream and i talked about the war of art
called lark can you see that yeah yeah
yeah logo where i was
i was a character called largo in a
dream anyway so i i had a budge
called logo that's amazing but that was
you know memorial so i think that was
what you did when you went to canada it
was a great thing that you did
i take my hat and look at you know the
bulging discs turned out to be one of
the best things that happened to you
i couldn't agree more i wonder how many
people again that are listening can
try and think about what small symbols
symbolic gestures they can make to
themselves and to the world around them
you know like how do you self define now
so previously i would have
i remember this was only at the start of
this year i went to a party
and i uh we were surrounded by
very very rich british aristocracy and
the guy that organized london 2012 and
people were asking also what do you do
what do you do what do you do
and i remember feeling almost this pride
in saying oh well that's a very long
that's a very long answer i do this and
i do this and i do this and i do this
and now i just say i'm a podcaster
because that is how i've chosen to
self-define and i wonder whether there's
people listening
who are moonlighting as a dance teacher
or as a football coach or as a an artist
or a comedian or whatever it is
but they still self-define as job title
who has an interest in doing this
you know like the sub the subtext the
subtitle um
so you know even that as a symbolic
gesture how do you self define yeah
yeah i can tell you for me it took me
probably 30 years before i could say
with a straight face i'm a writer
you know and i i think a lot of times we
can sort of say well let me
i'll just claim that identity now
prematurely and i'm not so sure that
works i think sometimes
it doesn't but it certainly is great you
know i mean you are a podcaster chris so
you said it you did it that's great you
got to earn it right you got to earn it
through the self-doubt and the imposter
syndrome
and the the complete lack of confidence
and everything else that comes with it
yeah i i got anybody feel any better i'm
just starting a new book right now
and i am completely terrified and i have
no idea if it's the right thing
that you know i just don't the only
thing i'm telling myself is just
just keep going for a while you know
just keep get
you know 80 or 90 pages and and then
worry about it you know
but i'm as terrified as anybody um
half a century of writing words down and
you're starting a new book you're
terrified
but i i think that's good you know i
think that's that's the way
it ought to be you know doesn't it show
that you can even michael jordan when he
came back
after playing baseball came back to
basketball he was scared you know he
said
no am i going to be able to do this i i
have a friend
who's been on the show a very famous dj
called christoph
supported eric pridz played some of the
biggest festivals in the world
and he every set this is a man who i've
known djing i've watched dj for 15 years
he's played to 20 000 people arenas
toured with the biggest djs on the
planet and before every set
even now he'll have played half a
thousand sets he'll have done
he feels sick they have a sick bucket
ready from before he goes on
every single time and it's because he
cares it's because he gives a [ __ ]
yeah i think that's good i think that's
a great sign
even though it might not be fun for him
he doesn't feel it at all
it's not fun but it's i think that's the
way it ought to be
if you get complacent and you think i
got this down
that's not good you've touched on
something there which was a question i
had
is it possible to fully defeat
resistance and it feels like a bank
account that you need to put money into
every day to overcome
it feels like that's never defeated you
know it's sort of
i always resistance really gives meaning
to life
just like the devil gives meaning to
you know any pursuit of anything if if
it wasn't there you know
so it's a good thing that it is there
that we do have to slay that dragon
every morning
the same thing with death right like the
reason that life has meaning is the fact
that it's going to end
yeah yeah we might not be happy about it
but you know
yeah true that's the way it works um i
have a final question for you which i
was listening to you on
lex friedman's podcast i highly
recommend anyone who's listening
to go and check that episode out uh and
your description was that were spiritual
beings trapped in a physical form
what did you mean by that um well i'd
certainly that's not original with me
you know
but i i absolutely do feel that that
we're
um that life exists on two levels you
know that there's the
material level that we're on you know
where the everyday world where we have a
body but then there's a higher level
above us and the artist is trying to
reach that that level you know so is the
athlete
so is anybody that's trying to reach
that sort of flowed sort of state you
know
and and i think um that we on this level
we sort of remember that level we have
you know
we can't put our finger on it but we
know that
you know and i also think that when we
see
some when we're on the material plane
and we see somebody act according to the
rules
of the higher plane it moves us
tremendously
you know somebody that uh runs into a
burning building to save a
child that they don't even know that's
you know that kind of thing um
so yeah i definitely think that we are
uh
we're spiritual be i don't know why
we're in bodies
you know god must have some plan you
know there must be some concept we're
doing penance or we're trying to learn
something or i don't know what
but um but definitely um i always define
much people say well what is you what is
your job and i just say
i'm a servant of the muse and what i
mean by that is i'm
i'm serving this level i'm trying to
communicate to that level
and and play according to the rules of
that level as much as i can
they say that true hell is when the
person that you are meets the person you
could have been
and i suppose that gap between the yeah
the physical and the astral or the the
the literal and the
the spiritual i suppose that's the gap
which we're all trying to close
yes i think so oh that's where all the
pain anxiety all that comes where
addiction comes from is that gap
all the fun stuff that's right yeah yeah
and i suppose that's also the gap
between amateur and professional so all
maps are yes i think so
even today's been wonderful when can we
expect
you back on to talk about this new book
is it going to be 2021
is it going to be 2022 i'd love to do it
uh
uh the book comes out in march you
better get the shuffle on then here it
is it's called a man
in arms and it's a novel oh wow um and
uh
so let's put it on the uh
put it on the on this on the schedule
somewhere
we'll get you whatever you want sometime
in the new year that'd be great chris
wonderful um
anything else that people should check
out online obviously link to the war of
art and turning pro will be in the show
notes below
is there anywhere else you want to send
people well actually i do have a little
uh talk about amateur i do have a kind
of a no
video series going on right now on
instagram and stuff it's called the
warrior archetype
and i'm sure if you kind of search for
it's like on two days a week like
just me on camera film by my girlfriend
diana
and edited by my friends jeff and matt
and um it's a it's two times a week and
it's gonna go
for i don't know into the new year
somehow i'm just kind of talking about
that
the thing that you access when you're
playing qriket and we're doing that
other thing the warrior
archetype i love it steven thank you so
much for your time it's been a real
pleasure hey great
pleasure to meet you and let's do this
again and thanks for having me chris
and my best to all of your viewers and
listeners
[Music]